SAM DUTTON: And I think
we're off, yeah?
We're all ready to go.
I think we're live and
broadcasting now.
The wonders of real-time
communication.
We've crossed over and just to
say hello and apologies for
the problems earlier of trying
get us hooked up.
But we are up and running now.
So just to introduce myself--
my name is Sam Dutton.
I'm a developer advocate for
Google Chrome based in London,
coming from London today.
Yeah, we've got people from
all around the world.
So if we could just cross over
to the others now, and people
could introduce themselves
and see who's here.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Hi, I'm
Justin Uberti.
MALANET: Hi, I'm Malanet
[INAUDIBLE].
TOM: And I'm Tom [INAUDIBLE].
SERGE LACHAPELLE: And I'm from
Stockholm, I'm Serge
Lachapelle.
SAM DUTTON: Fantastic.
It's great to see
everyone here.
So what we're going to today is
we're going to kind of give
an overview of WebRTC and see
where we are now, and talk
through, just very quickly,
the sort of basics of the
technology, and then really
go over the questions.
We've had great questions on
Moderator from everyone.
So thanks very much
for that stuff.
First, I'd just like to just
give you two inspirational
quotes from people
that I've heard.
And the first one is from
Brendan Eich, who's the
inventor of JavaScript.
And he says that's be believes
that "WebRTC is a new front in
the long war for an open
and unencumbered
web," so strong words.
And another quote from Phil
Edholm, blogger, who says
that, "Potentially WebRTC and
HTML5 could enable the same
transformation for real-time
communications that the
original browser did
for information."
So it's strong stuff.
And we believe that WebRTC
has huge potential.
So for those who are kind of new
to the topic, just a very
quick overview of what
WebRTC actually is.
And it's kind of a collection
of standards for real-time
plug-in free video, audio,
and data communication.
Now there are some existing
services that
do stuff like this--
Google Talk and Skype
and so on.
But all of these use plug-ins.
And we believe that WebRTC
can do real time more
efficiently than that.
So the first question, I guess,
people are asking is,
well, what do I need
to do WebRTC?
Well, you're going to need a
source of streaming video, or
audio, or, in the
future, data.
You're going to need a way to
communicate that video, audio,
or data to other peers.
And you're going to have to
exchange some kind of messages
between each other to initiate
sessions, to close sessions,
and also, of course, to report
errors as they happen.
And you're going to need to be
able to exchange, between
peers, information about media
and configuration--
things like resolution
and format.
And of course, you're also going
to need ways to actually
let people get in touch
with each other.
So in terms of what WebRTC has
brought to the web, in terms
of APIs, we have MediaStream
for getting streaming data.
We have PeerConnection for
communicating data, and then
what we're going to be seeing
implemented is Data Channel as
a method of exchanging
streaming data.
So a really powerful
set of APIs there.
Now, that's looking on
the client side.
If we go to the server,
WebRTC, real-time
communication, is always
going to need
servers, however simple.
You need for users to be able to
discover each other, users
to be able send in details to
each other, and communication
that can survive network
glitches.
And so that client applications
can send data
about the media they're working
with, like I said.
So information about resolution,
format, and so on.
And we also-- this is
very important--
of course, lots of client
applications are going to be
behind net gateways--
firewalls and so on.
And so WebRTC client
applications are going to need
to be able to communicate
across those barriers.
So thinking from the server
side, WebRTC needs two types
of server-side functionality.
You need stuff to do user
discovery communication
signaling between clients, and
then you need servers that can
help with net traversal and
streaming data communication.
So what I would suggest is, if
you haven't done so already,
especially if you're to WebRTC
is, do take a look at Justin
Uberti's video from Google
I/O. You can
find that on YouTube.
So Justin Uberti's WebRTC Google
I/O video, which is
great stuff.
And if you want to find
out more about
getUserMedia, the sort of--
what you might have seen in
terms of stuff for using media
stream-- take a look
at the HTML5 Rocks.
HTML5rocks.com has a lot of
great documentation about
using media streams, in
particular of course,
getUserMedia.
Now, what I would also suggest
is having a look, initially,
to get your head around the
idea of peer connection.
And if you looked at WebRTC.org,
you'll find some
great information there.
But one of the sites I would
recommend just to begin
looking at peer connection is
WebRTC-demos.appspot.com,
that's WebRTC-demos.appspot.com.
And we will have links for these
available on the site.
And then, once you've understood
something of peer
connection, what you need to
do, I think, is move on to
significalling and data
communication.
And a great place to start that
is appRTC.appspot.com.
And again, we'll put the
links up for that.
So just to get straight down
here, we've, like I said, had
some great questions from people
who are coming in to
see what they'd like to
find out about WebRTC.
So I'm just going to go over
now to the questions.
And see what we've got on
Moderator, and then ask our
panel of experts here.
So OK, just starting straight
at the top.
And, I guess Serge, I'll let
you dive in and see who you
think might be best
to answer this.
First question is from AIDGAB,
coming from Kazan.
Please give some explanation
about how media can be
broadcast using peer
connection.
Are there any relays that
can be used with WebRTC?
I think there's a couple of
questions inherent in this.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Justin, you
want to take that one?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Sure.
So the basic idea of doing a
multi-party communication,
there's a couple ways that
you can approach this.
One way is that you could
create multiple peer
connections, one to each
participant, and create what's
called a mesh network.
And for small conferences,
this can
actually work pretty well.
You basically send your video
and audio to every other
participant, and they
do the same.
But, as you probably have
noticed, as this gets to
larger conferences, this
becomes less efficient.
And so this is where the fact
that we're working with the
ITF and using standard protocols
allows others to
create what we call
middle boxes.
Middle boxes can be conferencing
servers that can
do various things like
a traditional--
what they call an MCU.
An MCU basically takes all the
incoming video feeds, in this
case from each peer connection,
would composite
them into a single image, and
then would send it back out
as, basically, the
group video with
everybody's picture and sound.
And WebRTC doesn't provide this
technology per se, but
you can create it using--
there are various products
that exist in internet.
Things like Asterisk, other
services that people are
creating based on WebRTC that
will be able to ride this sort
of functionality.
And then secondly, instead of
also doing that sort of
compositor, you can also
think of these
things are simple relays.
That, when the data comes in, it
gets sort of broadcast out
to all participants.
And, again, these are things
that you can create using
standard RTP protocols
because that's what
WebRTC is built upon.
SAM DUTTON: Thanks very much.
One thing I'd like
to clear up--
I guess I think when I was first
looking in WebRTC and
trying to get my head around
it, there was some stuff
relating to the different server
technologies that came
up that was really new to
me as a web developer.
And I was wondering if
one of you guys could
talk us through that.
So the three specific things I'm
talking about are-- well,
the ICE Framework, and what that
consists of, and how TURN
servers work, and what's a STUN
server, how does this
stuff work?
And why do we need it?
And how does it fit?
Where do I get one?
JUSTIN UBERTI: OK, so, it
is a confusing area.
In part it's because
the technology--
and the names are kind
of overloaded.
So when we talk about STUN, STUN
could be a mechanism for
actually retrieving your IP
address as seen by the outside
world from a STUN server.
So it could also be the method
through which you do ICE.
The type of connectivity check
message that you send from one
side to the other are called
STUN messages.
And recognizing this, the
authors of STUN have changed
the acronym that STUN means
over time-- from being one
specific thing now, it's
Session Traversal
Utilities for Nat.
It's kind of like a bag
of different tricks.
Well anyway, so what does this
mean to the developer.
Well, let's back up and look at
the fundamental part of the
ice process.
And Ice is Interactive
Connectivity Establishment.
In a nutshell, what ICE involves
is that the client on
either side will go and retrieve
as many IP addresses
as they can find.
Typically, this will be if the
local IP address, the IP
address of its actual network
adapter, the STUN address,
which is basically what the
outside world sees your IP
addresses as being.
You send a ping to a STUN
server, and the STUN server
replies back with the IP
address that it saw
that ping come from.
And that gives you your
outside address.
And then lastly, you can ask
TURN server, which is
basically a network interface
in the cloud, if you will.
And it's an IP address in the
cloud that you can kind of
access and, in some cases,
this is the one you'll
actually want to use.
Now as I mentioned, each client
server retrieves these
addresses, the STUN, the TURN,
and local address, and they
send them to the other side and
then both sides basically
send checks from their network
interfaces to these addresses
they've been provided
with by a peer.
And they figure out which ones
are actually usable for
sending and receiving data.
And whichever one ends up being
the one that works and
is the most efficient is
the one that's actually
used for the call.
So looking back, the
terminology, ICE is the
process through which these
checks are done.
TURN is the actual server that
lives in the cloud that
provides you with a sort of
IP address in the cloud.
In cases where your
STUN address
isn't immediately usable.
And there some cases, depending
on your NAT behavior
where the STUN address just
won't work for actual
communication.
And then STUN, is, in addition
to this sort of bag of
utilities for making all this
stuff happen, it's the type of
server that's used to discover
your NAT address, and it's the
type of sort of
connectivity-check message
that's sent from client
to client as
part of the ICE process.
Does that all make sense?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, thank
you, thank you.
Serge, I think you've got
a nice diagram up there.
Should we go over to that?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Ah yeah, that's
a great diagram.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah,
can we see this.
So yeah, but maybe we could just
talk through that briefly
and see what's there?
JUSTIN UBERTI: So right, I mean
this is a great diagram.
It shows two peers, each
behind a NAT device.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Oops,
Justin, I think
you got muted, sorry.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Sorry.
OK, as I was saying, so we
have two peers here each
behind NAT.
And then the relay server, which
is also known as the
TURN server, typically,
and STUN server.
And the peer contacts the STUN
server can learn the address
of its NAT.
[INAUDIBLE]
TURN server can learn the
IP address in the cloud.
And then it shares those
addresses with remote peer
through the cloud.
And then they perform the
connectivity checks.
That part isn't shown here.
But basically, we could figure
out what pathway the media can
actually take.
And for most consumer NATs,
it'll be the STUN address.
Because the NAT basically says
that the address learned from
the STUN server can also be
used for communication.
On some enterprise-grade NATs,
the rules are a little
different, that the address
learned from the STUN server
can't actually be used
for communication
with a remote peer.
And in these cases, at least one
side will need to use the
relay server in order
to get the media
from one side to another.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Great.
SAM DUTTON: That's brilliant.
I guess they way I understand
it, just correct me if this is
wrong, so the understanding I
have is that when you're using
WebRTC, essentially, the
framework will attempt to make
a direct connection between the
peers and if that fails
will revert to using
a relay server.
That's probably a gross
simplification but is that
something like what's
happening here.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Yeah, that's
exactly what going on.
I would say it's a little bit
more than that because rather
than have to sort of try one
thing, and then only fall back
and use the other thing if it
fails, and have a delay
associated with that, we're
kind of trying all these
things in parallel.
And that may mean that we use
the relay connection first,
and then we maybe find out later
that another connection
is actually better.
And in a case like that, we can
get the call running as
soon as possible on the first
connection we have and then
maybe transition to a more
efficient connection type as
the actual ICE process
proceeds.
SAM DUTTON: Gotcha, so it's not
just about connectivity.
It's about efficient
connectivity and data transfer.
OK, I'm just going to go over to
the questions again because
we've got a stack of
good ones here.
So yeah, this is a question a
lot of developers are asking.
From Fred in [INAUDIBLE] in
Germany, "When will data
connections be available for
developers." So I guess
thinking here about
data channels.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: So I
can answer that one.
We've posted our roadmap
on the Chromium blog.
So if you search on the Chromium
blog and for WebRTC,
you'll find it there.
Basically we first want to go
into Chrome stable with just
audio and video.
And once that's working well,
we'll start cranking on the
data channel thing.
So it's just a question of
having to focus and prioritize
things properly.
And so we decided to go with
audio and video first.
And right after that, once
you've seen audio and video go
from behind a flag into the
public Chrome, that's a good
signal that we're starting
to work on the
data channel stuff.
SAM DUTTON: Cool, cool It's
incredibly powerful.
I don't know who'd like to
just talk this through.
But data channel is going to
be a whole other set of
possibilities for all kinds
of applications.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Oh absolutely,
it basically changes any web
application into a peer-to-peer
application.
And by providing great tools
built in-- we'll have support
for unreliable and
reliable data and
things like flow control--
we basically solve a lot of
the problems that P2P apps
right now have to solve
themselves.
So the bag of tools that we're
going to be providing web
developers in a really
easy-to-use package, I think
is just going to be very
transformative.
There's all sorts of
applications that need to send
a lot of data, or send data
with very low latency.
And what they'll be able to
do with this API should be
incredible.
SAM DUTTON: One of the questions
I've had personally
is people asking, what's the
relationship between web
sockets and so WebRTC.
Are these two technologies
doing the same thing or
something different?
JUSTIN UBERTI: Well, they're
slightly different, but
conceptually they're
kind of the same.
They're a pipe that you want
to be able to send data to
somebody else in any format.
And so a web socket will
transmit a server, because
it's done over HTTP and goes
to a web server, whereas a
data channel will go
directly to a peer.
Now those kind of differences
don't really affect the
overall architecture of
how you can send data.
And so what we've done is we've
created an API for the
data channel that matches what
the web socket API is
syntactically.
And so if you have an
application that's written to
use web sockets, you should be
able to transition it to use
data channels extremely easily
because we've tried to keep
that difference as small
as possible.
And in most cases, the syntax
should be identical.
But the real difference is that
a web socket is always
reliable, there's no support
for unreliable data, and it
always goes to a server.
A data channel will always will
go to a peer, although
the peer could be a server.
You could also talk to a server
if you wanted to send
unreliable data to a server.
But it has a lot more
flexibility in terms of what
the actual communication
protocol should be because
we're not having to constrain
ourselves to HTTP.
SAM DUTTON: OK, thanks
for that.
Just going over to a very
specific question on the
Moderator questions here
from Lorenzo Minero.
He's asking, "Are you going
to add a way to specify
resolution and frame rate
for an outgoing stream?
Would this is the media stream
property or something that
would need to be adjusted
to via JSEP?"
Just before we go into that,
maybe a little quick
explanation about JSEP.
Now, what people may have seen
was the original WebKit peer
connection object, which has
become WebKit deprecated peer
connection.
Now, the idea of this is that
the original implementation
pre-JSEP, the demos that used
that stuff and applications
could still use that format.
And now, as we move on to JSEP
implementations before full
standardization, that we can
call those by a different
name-- peer connection, 00,
something like that.
Maybe Justin would like to just
tell us a little bit more
about that, or maybe
for Tommy.
TOM: So--
and if you are really
interested this.
If you look at the latest
editor's draft of the peer
connection standard, you'll
see that we have objects
called media constraints.
That's not the final name.
But they will contain
constraints that are either
optional or mandatory.
So you can say that, I want a
video at at least 320 pixels.
But I they really want to
have 640-wide video.
And that can be--
those kind of specifications can
be added when you create
the peer connection, but also
when you create your own
answer or create your offer.
And also when you add your
stream to the peer connection.
So yes. there will be complete
configurability for this.
SAM DUTTON: Great,
thanks very much.
Interesting stuff.
A couple of questions
from that Ted at
Cloudeo based in Poland.
I guess that's Poland, Poland.
But a couple of good
questions.
Firstly asking, "Do you plan to
add an ability to transmit
multiple streams using a
single VPN connection?
I'm thinking about a
conferencing server built
using WebRTC library that will
use single peer connection per
participant." Who would
like to take that?
JUSTIN UBERTI: I can
speak to that one.
We've got the addstream API,
where you can basically add a
stream to a peer connection.
But there is obviously no reason
why you couldn't add
more than one stream.
And especially on the remote
side, you could have the
remote side, if you have some
conferencing server, add
multiple streams to your
incoming peer connection.
And you'd be notified as to
each one of these streams.
And the mechanism for which this
is done is we're thinking
that within a given RTP session
that's on a peer
connection, you can have what
we call multiple SSRC And an
SSRC corresponds to a
media stream track.
And then tracks, as you know,
go into a media stream.
And so you could imagine in a
multi-user conference you
could end up getting multiple
media streams, and then
basically each meda stream
would correspond to a
participant.
And then each stream would have
a track for audio and a
track for video for each
participant's audio and video.
SAM DUTTON: Thanks very much,
that's interesting stuff.
Another question from the
moderator stream that we're
getting here.
This is from the Dimitri
in Moscow.
The question is, "We need a way
to save and send recorded
video and audio via media
stream record, which was
announced on Google I/O 2012.
When will appear in Chrome?"
Before we answer that, just one
thing I'd like to-- just a
warning, really, that people may
have seen on the web blog
posts talking about platforms
that implement WebRTC, where
in fact the platforms have
actually only implemented
getUserMedia.
There's, of course, more to
WebRTC than just getUserMedia.
There's the whole,
actual real-time
communication part of it.
But going back to the question,
maybe Serge, if you
could take this one.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Sure.
There's been a ton of requests
for being able to record media
locally from the browser.
And unfortunately, the API for
media recording isn't fully
baked right now.
So we're kind of taking a step
back and letting the standards
process do its thing.
And when there's a stable draft,
we will start working
on implementing that.
Right now we'll be focusing on
real-time audio and video
going forward.
SAM DUTTON: OK, thanks
very much.
Another question that we've had
from a lot of developers.
Going over to [? Hersian ?]
from Hazara in Pakistan.
"Is there any possibility for
audio-only communication among
peers in future.
That is audio tag can understand
remote streams and
generated blogs." And I
think I'll give this
to Malanet, I think.
MALANET: Yeah.
I think that that's definitely
possible.
I mean, you can have
it [INAUDIBLE]
[? spend ?] having this
[? article. ?]
And right now we aren't
implementing that tag, but we
are in the process of
implementing a tag according
to that feature.
SAM DUTTON: OK, thanks
very much.
Another question from
Ted at Cloudeo.
He's asking about HTTP
streaming fallback.
The IETF WebRTC use cases and
requirements doc has NF37
requirements stating that the
browser must be able to stream
data using HTTP.
Any idea on how you plan
to achieve this?
JUSTIN UBERTI: So I'll
take this one.
There are a bunch of techniques
that apps today use
to work over HTTP because most
of our communication apps we
run in environments where the
firewalls basically knock down
everything except HTTP.
And we still need to work.
And so WebRTC needs to work
in this scenario too.
And there are a bunch of tricks
that can be done to
accomplish this.
I won't go into all the details,
but one easy one is
to do HTTP Connect, which is
kind of the way that SSL is
used to connect through
an HTTP proxy.
And basically, an SLL
connection, the data is opaque
to the proxy or opaque to
whatever's making this
connection.
And so if we send our data and
make it look HTTPS then,
basically, we can go
through proxies.
We can go through things that
are restricting to HTTP and
HTTPS only.
And this is obviously a very
important part of making sure
WebRTC can work everywhere.
And servers, turn servers and
such, will need to sort of be
aware, when you're making
extensions to the
specifications, to deal with
being able to allocate ports
and stuff like that over
HTTPS instead of over
just vanilla TCP.
But like I said, it's already
in use today in various
products, and it'll definitely
find its way into WebRTC.
SAM DUTTON: Cool, cool,
thanks so much.
We've got a question about
protocols, actually, but this
raise, to my mind, it's a big
question about the way
signaling works with WebRTC.
And one thing about WebRTC is
that so it doesn't make
specifications for
signaling methods
or signaling protocols.
And as I understand it, the kind
of name this architecture
has been called JSEP.
And I'm just wondering if is one
of the people we're with
there could just give us a
little bit more detail.
What is this JSEP thing?
And what was the design process
that led to that.
So some talk about protocols,
signaling, and the
methods we can use.
Because I've seen different
approaches using XHR, and the
channel API Google,
or with websites.
So yeah, maybe Serge could
kick this off.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: So JSEP
means JavaScript--
God, I always forget the E.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Establishment.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Establishment,
thank you.
JavaScript Establishment
Protocol.
And it reuses the strength
of the browser.
Browsers are great at
communicating over HTTP.
And so JSEP reuses that channel
for all its signaling
and what JSEP gives us are a
low-level API that allows us
to then encapsulate other
protocols on it.
So it's really protocol-neutral.
And so we think that JSEP
strikes a good balance for web
developers that want to get up
and running quickly, and more
advanced developers that might
want to encapsulate other
established voice-over-IP
protocols or create their own
more advanced protocols.
So it's really a lower-level
API that allows you to
encapsulate other protocols.
JUSTIN UBERTI: And we're seeing
people do great stuff
with this already.
People already have SIP
in the browser.
It's something called SIPML5.
By taking the JSEP API and
converting it into SIP.
And we've already seen other
things where the API can be
converted into XMTP.
The whole idea behind JSEP is
to not bake the signalling
protocol in the browser.
So that applications can use
whatever they need, whether
it's SIP, whether it's XMTP,
whether it's something custom
to the application, and not
constrained by the API.
And so far we're seeing
that work out
exactly as we had intended.
SAM DUTTON: Cool, OK, thanks.
I just realized we've got about
three minutes to go.
So another couple of
quick questions.
Again, something I've heard from
developers, from Matt in
the United States-- "How
is security handled?
Could chat sessions be
intercepted or accessed by
third parties?" Maybe, Serge?
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Well, we've
taken the opportunity, when
designing and proposing this API
and the protocols, to make
sure that encryption
was turned on
from the very beginning.
So encryption for communication
peer-to-pere is
not an option.
It's on by default.
And so right now, at the ITF
there are discussions on what
types of encryption
and what types of
authentication to use.
But I think there's strong
sentiment to have encryption
be on from the start.
Maybe Justin can fill in where
our implementation is in
regards to encryption today.
JUSTIN UBERTI: Right, so we
support SRTP, which is a
secure RTP in our current
implementation right now.
And as Serge mentioned, that's
going to be the standard it's
been required for
implementations of WebRTC.
And that uses AES and
SHA1, really, it's
state-of-the-art security.
And we're also looking at
doing something a step
further, which is something
called DTLS SRTP, which uses
the datagram TMS protocol to
set up the keys for SRTP,
which makes it a lot harder
for any sort of man in the
middle or anything like
that to be able to
interface to the keys.
Because the keys are,
basically, only
know by either side.
And it provides a little bit
more traditional guarantee
that, not only is the media
secure, but that the keying
and everything like that has
been done in a form that's
future-safe.
SAM DUTTON: Cool, OK.
And another question we've,
again, had from a lot of
developers is just wondering
when we might see WebRTC
implemented in Chrome
for Android.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Android, and
mobiles in general, are
extremely interesting for us.
As a team, we've decided to
iterate on the API spec and
help the API get to 1.0 version
using the desktop.
So that's really been how we've
been executing currently.
We've been working on the
desktop to be sure that we can
provide good strong feedback
to the W3C and the ITF.
Now once we come out from behind
the flag, and the API
has reached a stable state,
we're going to start cranking
on mobile as well.
So if you look at the
code.webrtc.com, you'll see
there's a lot of mobile
components
that are there already.
We'll just need to package it
all in into nice WebRTC for
the Chrome browser on Android.
But first, desktop.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, and that
brings me to my final question
actually, which again
there's a few of
these on the Moderator.
If we could just have an
overview of where we are now
with implementation on the
desktop in Chrome.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: So you
probably saw, a blog post
recently about getUserMedia.
And so that's the ability to
access basic webcam and
microphone from the browser.
And that's going
into Chrome 21.
In Chrome 22, we're going to
add the ability to remember
decisions for secure websites.
So if you're on an HTTPS
website, you'll be able to
always allow certain websites
to use the camera and
microphone.
And this is going to make many
web app developers very happy.
So then we won't have to press
the allow buttom all the time.
Post that, we've just gotten
a new draft from the W3C
specifying the WebRTC API.
We think that this draft is good
enough now to implement,
and modify our implementation
a little bit, and try to get
that from behind a the flag.
I don't know exactly where on
the Chrome releases we're
going to end up, but fairly soon
we're going to be coming
out from behind the flag.
SAM DUTTON: That's
fantastic news.
Thanks very much
for joining us.
If you'd like to find out more
about WebRTC, please look
WebRTC.org or we've got an
introductory article about
WebRTC on HTML5rocks.com.
We'll put the links to all
that stuff, all those
resources on the post for this
hangout and on WebRTC.
And we'll tweak that
and so on.
And just to apologize for the
late start time today, really
apologize for the technical
problems we've had with
real-time communication.
And thank you so much
for joining us.
And we'll have to be having
more hangouts
like this in the future.
And just a big thank you to
all of the panel today for
spending valuable
time with us.
SERGE LACHAPELLE: Thank you, I
look forward to doing this
soon again.
SAM DUTTON: Yeah, So thank
you Justin, Malanet,
and Tommy and Serge.
It's been fantastic.
JUSTIN UBERTI: It was
fun to be here.
SAM DUTTON: OK.
See you guys.
MALANET: Bye-bye.